en esta ocasión nos piden emparejar cada
función con el intervalo en el que
aparece en la gráfica siguiente
esta es la gráfica y como ven tenemos
aquí dos funciones una con esta forma y
otra con esta y aquí abajo nos están
poniendo las fórmulas que podrían estar
relacionadas con estas gráficas y el
intervalo en el que valen noten que aquí
tenemos varios intervalos 2 menor o
igual que xy x menor a 6 pero no menor o
igual en la gráfica las bolitas cerradas
significan que es este punto o igual a
este punto las bolitas abiertas
significan que son mayores menores pero
no iguales a este punto entonces vamos a
analizar algunos puntos de estas
gráficas para identificar los intervalos
de los puntos y las funciones que les
corresponden para esto vamos a usar
nuestro pizarrón electrónico para poder
hacer algunas anotaciones con mayor
facilidad
muy bien aquí he puesto nuestra gráfica
y la sección de intervalos y funciones
que tenemos que relacionar con éstas
comencemos encontrando los intervalos
que nos interesan veamos este punto en
la gráfica el que esté cerrado o el que
esté lleno quiere decir que este punto
en el eje x toca al valor menos 3 es
decir este intervalo incluye al valor
menos 3 y eso lo vamos a representar con
este paréntesis cuadrado de acá para
indicar que se incluye al valor menos 3
y ahora veamos este otro punto de acá
este es un punto abierto quiere decir
que quiere decir que el intervalo no va
a tocar al valor 12 en x
va a ser menor que este valor pero no va
a ser igual a este y esto lo vamos a
representar con este paréntesis que
cierra aquí y este rango lo podemos
expresar así con el paréntesis cuadrado
menos 3,2 y el paréntesis que cierra
indicando que esté menos 3 va a ser
incluido en el intervalo pero el 2 no
así pues eso lo expresamos como menos 3
que es menor o igual a equis que a su
vez x es menor pero no igual a 2
y ese es el intervalo de esta función de
la izquierda hagamos lo mismo con la
función de la derecha vemos que tiene
aquí un punto cerrado y este punto toca
al eje x en el valor 2 como es un punto
cerrado quiere decir que este valor 2 se
incluye en el intervalo y no lo
expresamos con este corchete cuadrado de
aquí analicemos el otro extremo de esta
función y vemos que es un punto abierto
que toca el eje x en el valor 6 pero no
lo va a incluir entonces dibujamos
nuestro paréntesis que cierra indicando
que el intervalo no va a incluir al
valor 6 lo vamos a escribir para el de
6-4 2-6 paréntesis que cierra y eso
significa que tenemos el intervalo que
va de 2 menor o igual a equis y x es
menor pero no igual a 6 y ya que
encontramos estos intervalos vamos a
ubicarlos en las opciones que nos dan
acá para ver cuáles son los que
corresponden a estas funciones el
intervalo
corresponde a las funciones de la
derecha es 2 menor o igual que x menor
que 6 y el que corresponde a la función
de la izquierda que damos que es menos 3
menor o igual que x menor que 2 bueno
ahora tenemos que encontrar cuáles de
estas funciones representan a nuestras
gráficas y para encontrarlas vamos a
ubicar puntos en las gráficas que
evaluaremos en las fórmulas de estas
funciones para encontrar las que
correspondan veamos voy a elegir este
punto que está bastante sencillo menos
y en caso de que necesite otro punto
para asegurarme de encontrar la fórmula
correcta voy a elegir este punto de aquí
que es el 0 - 3
el balón es el primer punto en las
fórmulas y me acabo de dar cuenta que
aquí puse ser un lugar de seis
el punto es menos 36 bueno tomemos el
valor de xy sustituyamos 2 en la primera
fórmula aquí tenemos x2 x es menos 3 - 3
- 2 es menos 5
- 5 al cuadrado es 25
16 25
41 y es la raíz cuadrada de 41 y aunque
yo no sé cuál es la raíz cuadrada de 41
estoy segura de que no es 6 ya que 6 x 6
636 así que esta función cita no es
veamos la siguiente aquí pongo x menos
tres menos dos es menos 5 menos 5 al
cuadrados 25 y aquí tengo 4 menos 25 4
menos 25 es menos 21 y bueno aquí la
raíz cuadrada de menos 21 pues es aquí
un concepto que involucraría números
imaginarios que no estamos analizando
aquí así que con más razón esta raíz
cuadrada de menos 21 pues tampoco hacer
6 veamos la siguiente función aquí está
mi x menos tres menos dos es menos 55 al
cuadrado es 25 16 menos 25
es menos 9 así que voy a escribirlo aquí
arriba porque no tengo espacio la raíz
cuadrada de menos 9 pues igual que en el
caso anterior estaríamos hablando de
números imaginarios para tratar de
encontrar la raíz cuadrada de números
negativos lo cual no estamos
contemplando aquí esta función tampoco
me sirve bueno veamos la cuarta función
menos tres más dos es menos uno menos un
al cuadrado es 116 menos uno es 15 aquí
quedaría la raíz cuadrada de 15 pero la
raíz cuadrada de 15 96 quedamos que 6 x
6 636 esta función tampoco es veamos la
siguiente sustituyó menos tres menos
tres va a ser menos 6 menos 6 al
cuadrado va a ser 36 y bueno está 36 no
es igual al 6 entonces esta función
tampoco nos sirve las siguientes
funciones menos x al cuadrado menos aquí
y sustituimos nuestro menos 3 en la
equis
al cuadrado más 3 - 3 al cuadrado es 9
menos 93 va a ser igual a menos 6
-6 no es igual a 6 así que esta función
tampoco nos sirve y no le puse que la
anterior tampoco nos servía le pongo el
tache bueno pues veamos la última
función que yo espero que ésta así sea
sustituimos nuestra x menos 3 al
cuadrado es 3 por 3 99 menos 36 y vaya
finalmente esta sí es la que corresponde
a nuestra función de la izquierda y
relacionamos esto con el intervalo que
ya habíamos encontrado que le
correspondía y vamos a iluminar este
circulito de aquí esta es la opción que
corresponde hagamos lo mismo con la
gráfica de la derecha qué punto me puede
servir aquí para evaluarlo vamos a
buscar un punto sencillo pues me puede
servir este punto de acá en donde la
gráfica toca el eje x que es el de 6,0 y
de la misma manera que hicimos con la
gráfica de la izquierda vamos a evaluar
este punto en todas estas funciones
comenzamos con la primera sustituimos
nuestra x que es en este caso 66 menos 2
4 al cuadrado 16 16 más 16 va a ser 32
esta es la raíz cuadrada de 32 pero la
raíz cuadrada de 32 no es 0 el resultado
que estamos buscando es cero así pues
esta función no nos sirve veamos la
siguiente seis menos dos creemos que es
44 al cuadrado 16 4 menos 16 es igual a
menos 12 y esta función nos da la raíz
cuadrada de menos 12 que como vimos en
ocasiones anteriores no va a ser nuestra
solución ya que la raíz cuadrada de un
número negativo implica el uso de
números imaginarios que no estamos
contemplando aquí y además de esa raíz
cuadrada cualquiera que sea va a ser
diferente de cero por lo que esta
función no nos sirve veamos la tercera
nuestra x 66 menos 200 44 al cuadrado es
16 16 menos 16 va a ser igual a cero
esta si funciona ya que la raíz cuadrada
de 0 va a ser cero esto nos está dando
el valor que buscamos así que la opción
que queremos
es está en el rango que le corresponde y
todas las demás funciones vamos a
ponerla en que no aplica ninguna todas
estas que no corresponde bueno
finalmente vamos a probar esto en la
plataforma de nuestra página aquí
bajamos un poco queramos que ésta no
está tampoco está así está no está no
está no y está aquí y veamos nuestra
respuesta es correcto